my name is Debra stern and I work for
promo hair international promo hair is
an organization that works with
low-income women in Latin America we
integrate microfinance and Financial
Inclusion services with healthcare
services and with empowerment training
and education
the women that we serve they may not
have any sort of business at all they
may be living very much at the poverty
level and we provide micro loans and
many of our clients advance from eking
out a living to having a small stall in
the market as an example to potentially
opening up a shop and employing other
people and employing their children so
Alejandra works out of the managua
office she works on communications there
one of the challenges and opportunities
that we have is to really collect the
on-the-ground stories of what's
happening and to plan donor visits
all Alejandra never ah hello Deborah how
are you pull moistness one of the
challenges of being in the role that I'm
in is that we do need to communicate to
our field offices and not a fluent
Spanish speaker so being able to talk
with Alejandra using translator has been
really terrific because we've been
making real plans we've been doing real
work but we've also been building a
relationship so we have to plan our trip
entonces tenemos que planea nuestra bc
de I'm really looking forward to coming
real mint estoy con and she has Devon
IVA so tell me something about the
clients you've selected when Tammy algo
sobre los clientes que hace el ejido
visitor a MOS una Killian pass they
producing me el en amitaba otra mujer en
su comunidad a linear second a yes we
will visit some clients who are working
in honey production and they have
invited other women in their community
to join them I wanted to just get a
little bit more information about
Gloria's background
quiero conseguir más información sobre
la historia de Gloria
era una mujer Muay Boran cuando escucho
pro mujer inicio comme un pequeño puesto
de tortillas she was a very poor woman
when she started in the group of pro
mujer she started with a small stand of
tortillas now she has a second shop at
the bus terminal en mi cuarto de negocio
she wants to improve her business
condition and the Vida casinos and give
better life conditions to her children
she started it from the very beginning
and it's grown to be the size it is now
Adriano commences daily nithya Kriya
sido el tamaño de Oda many of these
women only went to primary school their
children are graduating high school
going on to college going on to
technical school starting their own
businesses very much role models for
their children solo camera a little
Paris that is what drives women but a
Ferrara SOP for product offering a
Mikaela to prepare their children to go
to school
exactly the exact time anything we've
just bonded more through it where each
speaking our own language we have just
been able to talk more fluidly this
enabled us to become better friends
promo hair women are fundamentally very
courageous very brave
it's really about unleashing that human
spirit that human potential that is
really the Avenue to the future we all
won yes importante porque estamos
llegando
cada dia imam O'Hara della Perez and
that's important because each day we are
getting more women out of poverty
you